I thought you know fast me.
You know. I was a gig.
You know. Do you.
And judge joan oliver
and i charge.
I have one cell of a gate
and i fit into the scene.
I was born a year
or so about a year after my parents genova
and john gave me up to nimbin from sydney.
I was their first child
and i lived on paradise valley
which is coming just at an in
until i was about full time
until i was about eight.
I think and my dad me into lismore
and i decided to live with him and visit
mum or have you want to put. Peas.
Gave it a shot as i.
On weekends and that's about it
and turn it like i feel basically i
was one of the first home births in
then when i was a few years later
on two years after my sister.
I was no number 7 baby born
on the community. First. Yes.
First baby home birth on the community
basically lived there till i was about eight.
We our whole my mother. Knew
father that stage move down.
Here tomorrow by just nearby
and i have i basically was full time
at peavey till about the age of eight.
Early hours memories of nimbin.
Would have on the community with
a wide range of friends just as
my memory is this is a
one big happy family.
Basically there was no major
mother figure major father figure.
Everyone could turn to anyone
for any help anything.
You know was a big happy family.
Well i have a lot of memories
and i actually i've been thinking about
it because lots of people say oh my first
memory is of my mum doing
this also and i that.
I don't really know exactly what order
all my memories fit in. I know that.
Tonka toys.
I don't actually let's really talk about
these big family thing i don't really
remember a lot of the parents
my parents are always there.
Whenever you need them but they
weren't a big part of my life.
I mean they probably were that honest
that members i mean basically i member.
Always this group of friends like there was
jamie entirely in all these people who
are older than me and then
there was a group of friends
or my then there was those
who are younger than us.
Members if one particular place.
Were used up all the older the
older guys had tonka toys
and we'd make tonka toys cities
and remember mud really just i mean just
having so much fun in the outdoors like i
you know if i ever had a lot
of toys but i just know that.
I didn't have to have something material
in my hands i mean you could go outside
and we'd make mud pies
and bring them into mum
and she'd go big thing then cook them
in the oven and then we'd get side
and eat them.
So i'd have to say the earliest memories
are just of having a whole lot of fun just
with this group of friends like
children and. I mean there were adult.
Influences but basically just the kids
having so much fun would have to the.
Yeah. Bush experience.
A lot of exploring. Was a two i
think two hundred ten acre farm.
Anyway. Quite a large farm for small
kids to explore and so you know there's.
There's a great waterfall there with a
big swimming hole which basically the
community lived around in the summer.
You know just swim every day and there was
some without lots of kids our age old
and young as sally mentions these to be a
lot of trek stuff into the bush just by
ourselves. You know like
that we had the freedom to
that didn't have to be supervised
or you know we didn't have supervision
else just people join in might have been
older but you know we'd
head off into the bush and.
Those are lots of experience
with the bush and nature.
You know a lot of animals on the farm.
A lot of fun with that.
Now i've lived in so called suburbia i
guess is what most people want to hear
when i say the bush experiences
things like yes we.
At one stage we did have i mean we always
had sam i've never except for living with
dad every house. Mum been in is sam
i've built houses sort of things but.
Because i know this is to
another because like my parents
and the people who set up the community
came straight from the city.
I always remember there was always a
bathroom and there was always a kitchen.
I mean. So it wasn't like we are.
I mean we still had to use a gas lamps
every you know but that the main.
The bottom house which was what was the
first regional buildings always had
electricity
and always had all the latest mod cons
basically i mean that's the way i saw it
but.
The bush experience for me would have just
been as janice said we were just given
the freedom and the trust i think that's.
I mean i wasn't a conscious
thing then but reflecting back.
I mean you know my friends i know you
know my mum wouldn't let me do this.
My want to let me do that
and i mean yeah the creek was a
major source we just go for a day
explorations up the creek and we.
I know i wouldn't exactly said i would know
how to build my own house although i'm
sure my mum would disagree here that.
Oh you know a self-sufficient you know
because i think as kids we we were really
not asked to do a lot. I mean.
You know we didn't have tools.
So as such we were just given
the freedom to explore
and i mean i think the so-called
bush experiences has just given me.
I know you just you know i haven't meant
so much technical things of how to set up
this or do this that my city folk think
that that's what the bush
experience is all about.
But it's it's kind of you know a way of
life the way of looking at things sort of
like i think you've got a tall waterfall
and you want to get to the top.
You know how do you do it so i think he's
like i know that answer the question
or not. Really.
I remember. My biological
father and mother.
Through the school basically he
started up the community school
that i went to play a big part in my life.
So i was quite interesting relating them.
Relating to them as parents
as well as my teachers
and it was a very interesting
way to relate to them.
You know wasn't a father
figure. A mother figure.
You know for someone there to had all
this knowledge that we get out of them.
Stuff that in a fun way that.
I remember a lot of a lot of.
Good times laughing times with them
they always seem to be busy happy.
And i always like how ready to share share
the parenting like it wasn't like they
were like mum was like clucky hanover is
you know she's happy to lotus off find
other people and because you
know go spend time with us. So.
It was an interesting experience with
communities who well. So
i guess for them. Yeah.
The key really the school. I guess i need.
I don't know how many years i went there.
The main thing that the community
school i remember is kids circus.
And the school was in two
buildings there was.
The community school which has been
old commonwealth bank i think and
that was the main school
and it had. I know i mean.
It wasn't like a school because there
was rooms but there was a kitchen and
and because it was like it was like
a house really more than a bank
and so you know we do cooking as
in-home science but it would be.
I mean that's been in the way everyone
taught in the community school was it wasn't
like you were going to
learn how to make this.
It's oh yeah well if you managed
to make it at the end that's fine
but all the lessons along
the way is more important.
I still had this one memory
of we were making toffee.
I think it was and as
it was one stove and.
10 people making coffee you
know two people person.
What we're staring wagon
and the by the time the last
person had cooked their toffee
and ready to go to the next day
to first person toffee was hard.
So there was our first lesson and.
Then there was the lesson of if we use
a metal spoon we're going to get hot
but if we use a wooden spoon it's going to
burn in a freezer plastic spoon is going
to melt so which option is the best i
mean i have all these crazy memories
but i mean it's just great.
I mean basically i have
lots of just stories
and memories from the community school.
The other part of the community
schools the t s or the tomato sauce
and the to my source i
remember as a kid circa space
and would woodworks face down the like and
and pottery pottery was we had a
little wheel and things like that
and i have to tell you this
story. I was really on and.
We had we were going out to mom had decided
we're going to start doing some digs
or ing
and so she said right we're going to get
the jig saw you thought out this is great.
I want to get to show all my
friends my new camera the frog
and miss piggy did so puzzle that
i had just got the other day.
So we were up you know we had a bus.
I think it was we drove back to peavy
and mum got out he would take would work
jigsaw that cuts would and so i was going.
That doesn't look like
my teeth of hope so.
I mean that's the way you kind of learn
things it was like i mean the reason
that i had great fun
and i mean i remember.
I have to i'm i've got all these guys
and i currently terrible because
they are just a waste of time
but not answering the question what did
you really do school i'm members being.
On them when i first went
to a so-called proper.
I don't know what you want to
call public school really worried
that i wouldn't be up to scratch
but i now realise that.
I say maybe there wasn't you know.
The heaviest emphasis on let's getting
academic work but i learnt so.
So many other things so many
important things about life.
I mean not you know great life stories
i think you know nothing like that
but just so many things that have
changed and made me the way i am that.
You really wouldn't have got
in an ordinary school because.
I mean just and you know
just the way it was taught.
I mean as a start with
and i mean i member this kid circus i mean
i can talk about the kids echoes i have
to say. When the community school
first we had a day a week.
I think it was i'm not quite sure i
was so young. I just remember and.
It was just a major influence on my life
i was a clown later on i got nine baggy
pants but even when i first started i don't
think i had a name i was just a clown.
And i remember we did this you know got
our whole performance together and.
And we toured and it seemed to me
that we may as well have gone
to sydney it turned out now
that we only went to ballina but the
travel and the excitement and things like
that and i think i mean now there's no
way i can get up on stage and do all
that sort of stuff that
i used to like i could
but i'd go home on oscar you know i'll
get all embarrassed with that just.
It was good that it didn't
give you the confidence that.
Oh i'm so wonderful and
all this sort of stuff
but it gave me confidence in
yourself you didn't think
that you are better than anyone else just
because you were on stage you didn't
think that. Oh i don't know.
You know you just thought you
felt really confident in yourself
and you saw this is great and i
just remember having so much fun.
I mean you can really skills
a raid. It was like i mean.
I can i mean i can remember specifically
lessons i can you know one specific lesson
of learning about the parts were frog
and i mean you like i don't remember any
of this sort of stuff from you know public
schools. It's all just i yeah were. Had
to spell out who he went to right.
But just i don't know if it was
because it was that stage of my life
but i remember specific
incidents and things like that
that just really stand out and.
Go and help me get to
my boy economics period
that i mean my friends
still they still go.
Yeah i know you're just joking aren't you.
Really in a circus and
i tell my stories and.
Yeah you know community schools just.
As i said taught you a lot of stuff.
Not necessarily strict
academic stuff but. Damn fine.
Yeah i'd go along with that. Just
the style in which they taught it.
I my i have lots of memories
of the community school
but not one is actually learning like
being sat down and saying learn this.
You have to know if a test.
No tests and that nothing like
that basically is the sharing of
knowledge to the younger kids.
I mean i remember going to actual public
school for a short period of time
and being there.
You know no you know there's going to be
like proper academic questions with maths
and thing i sat down in a class of kids
my age not actually think you have i ever
done mass sat down with questions
and i breezed through them i was at the
top of the class by big majority right
when he was always like my teacher so here
i mean i had i had a rat's tail my hair
was shave i was a rat.
You know i didn't have a uniform i was just
you know i just a little hippy kid with
you know kind of shocked everyone
and here i was way ahead of everyone
else in my schooling academia side
and i was a kid i think the community
school was just wonderful. It really was.
I mean sour mention the surface hours
incredible that really was. But.
I mean i think. Biggest thing i still
have is the memory where i was a dog.
And i had to go out and do a
certain saying but i came in early
but of course the people watching.
They didn't know
but to me it was a big thing you
know i'd come in early on my act
and i know what should i do you know
the things that's cause a little kid
that was important to me
but i remember several scenes in like
performing in front of like a scene like
everyone in name would come out to see.
I remember performing in the the
butter factory the big concert.
No hall thing and we did a performance
there and it seemed like everyone.
In my whole world of nimbin was
there watching us on stage
and i was a real buzz that was really good
things like that are incredible. But.
I mean like doing the aboriginal studies.
You know i mean this day in age i mean you
know i need high school just about to go
into year 10. And like you
know you learn about australia
and sure you do aboriginals
they were natives today dada.
But you don't learn a really about them.
We had a man who just
knew so much about them.
We took camping trips up in rivers and
we joe and we basically live like them
and learnt about them and hunt like them
and it was just incredible like
you know here we were only young
but learning just incredible
skills and knowledge
that there's so many people
out there just won't know.
The whole lifetime and here we
were through the community school.
You know learning about such things
as that this incredible really was.
You know that that was just a point. Anna
said was amazing was. We learnt so much.
It was i mean.
Mainly because it wasn't categorized
into this is what you know and this year
and this is what you can only next year.
I have to say that although it was
different. The amount that i've learnt.
Well i can't say it was the time standard
if the sat in an island in the time span
of any man and the same time. Span.
Outside there was just although
i learnt a lot of other things.
It was just as i said all my memories are
from nimbin all my childhood memories.
Every memory that i always go back
and chuckle on is formed before i
left which was when i was eight.
So i have i have to say we
just learnt so much. It was.
I mean basically it just
provided a whole base.
I mean as mum was saying earlier
having all these different influences
and not having the teacher student
relationship not having that so you know
that so-called relationship.
It was good because you wouldn't just say
ah there just one teacher sort of thing
you think.
Well i respect this person so i actually
going to want to learn about what they
have to share and i think having such a
number of adults and a really broad base.
Means that we were able to
really say well i think
that idea is right and i
think that idea is wrong
and just a community school
the whole atmosphere
and environment really let us
learn just. So much really.
S
that i think is really important to base
your character for the rest of your life of
the afghan actual learning of it.
Like i said for wasn't in a teaching way
as such as we're used to in this you know
schooling system as well we
wouldn't sit down in class
and say we're going to learn this as
such and learn it. You have to know it.
It was i can't remember being taught
as such something direct we just
learnt it didn't they do it in practice.
Basically they want to teach us
something we'd go out and do it.
So we'd learn from it so out
of a textbook. You know.
We want to learn about the oceans and
how it worked. Would go to the ocean.
We'd spend a week camping on it
and we'd learn about it much more
than learn reading over textbooks.
You know it's just incredible
the way they taught it to us.
I think was the main thing
that made us learn so much.
This. Oh yeah.
And there was.
Yeah there was the public school
which was just down the road
and so there's a community
school in the public school
but i think the whole of nimbin
really just learnt to integrate
and you know.
One there wasn't wasn't segregation
like you know rednecks
and hillbillies things like an
american nothing like that at all.
Basically that i can recall
you know. I think there.
I have to just to do to gave you.
That's just different memories
and it wasn't there was.
I wouldn't even say separation
that's too strong a word there was.
There's the words a difference
and separation too strong.
There were the people who went
to the name and community school
and there were the people
who went to nimbin sensual
and every line times i used to track up
by their lunch and some job at the state.
We used to have the good old oh yes
and they used their house or us
and we used to hassle them
but going home on the bus together were
all friends so it was like it was there
but i never really think it got to be in
there was you know integrity stick i don't
know if that's right word. I'm not
really big on english but it was just.
It was there because i think we i
don't know if we had it was that
that was our you know
that society these groups
or if we were just having fun because
hey why not because i don't have
that he even nature or not
but it never in my experience never was
anything more than a friendly joke.
I mean i mean it might have
been for the older kids
but i mean as i said going on
the bus that wasn't a problem.
You know there was no two sitting next to
her anything like that because. I think.
I know. It was just there was two
different schools and you know.
We all we all still had you
know we're all still human.
So it wasn't really a problem.
I think that was good.
Having being i don't know that was
because of my age i was still in
that kind of naïve group where
everybody is my friend and
that you know i think
that's just another thing
and as we got out of nimbin it was like
well it doesn't matter you know i mean it
doesn't matter if
that person's driving a you know my side
is in this person's driving a bombed up
cars their friends their friends
or thing and i think that was.
Yeah
that was really you know the
positives really dinner table
one memory.
If you could call the memories of not having
any memory of ever getting in trouble.
Very as friends and i say my first
memory is when my mom hit me
or something like that which
is. And i mean i remember.
Without going into specific detail.
A few myself
and a few friends demolished
a certain space of a person.
I don't know that we even really
had a reason we did to begin with
but then i think we've got carried away
with demolishing this space basically
and all of its contents and member.
As soon as we'd finished were absolutely
horrified at ourselves. I mean.
We we were crying
and shaking just at the thought of because
we know we knew well he had done was
just so wrong it was just so out of line.
He was just i mean basically we knew
we'd been totally irresponsible and
and i guess also because we knew
that we deserved to you
know not have lost trust
but i mean we knew that we'd
broken trust and. And remember.
We we're just absolutely terrified
but we said right we we've got a dog
ourselves in we've done these horrific acts
you know we've got to do this so we went
and i don't even remember an angry voice.
I don't remember a person saying oh.
Tut tut. I mean i really don't.
All i remember was having to stick
newspaper between pages of wet books
that had been left out of night and.
But i don't think
that it was a situation where it
wasn't like we could get away with it
but it wasn't like we got in trouble.
Somehow we we we knew we learnt
from the whole process and learnt
that what we'd done was wrong
and you know went on from
that without having to be yelled at. I
mean basically i i was never yelled at.
I mean.
Oh that's not too well yes it is actually
i don't i mean i don't know if it's this
good of that block out the bad memories
but i mean we all had our disagreements
and i remember john and i used
to fight like tooth and nail.
But. Even even this is classic
memory even when we were fighting.
He still used to call me sal and
i still used to call him bines
but we became so do that and then usually
you know in some get them you know.
So we all come down
here sort of thing and.
Yeah i mean i remember joe
and i used to not get on
but we used to get on sort of being
that now i never really disciplined.
Yet we didn't turn out to be. Raucous.
Like rockets very we didn't turn out
to be i don't know rebels to society
or anything like that it was just i
think it was respect to smear surest.
Basically. Sally said like there was
never i mean i remember one case.
There was a very clear there was
a nothing on the side of female
and male didn't matter of thing all out.
Friends just a group of kids didn't matter
if they were girls didn't matter boys
you know been naked didn't mean a thing you
know we surround the farm with no close
on around it didn't you
know didn't matter.
But i mean i remember for some reason
this girl lucy came up said hi.
Jonah and i hit her. I mean as a first time
i've ever hit somebody my life i think.
I i stood there i didn't know why he does.
And she is today and you know why he.
I you know i hit her.
At this and she started crying on
and i went to bed which is just
another mother figure to said oh no.
Lucy came in crying said what happened
was i joana hit me for she counted
and everything and then becomes at the
meeting as oh why did you hit a joe
and i said. And i said.
Because she said hello and i think i'll
write a whole sitting here shaking.
No reason to be shaking so i
knew i'd never be hitter any
but still the factor does something wrong.
You know and she goes oh that's right.
They take no shit from
nobody. If they say hello.
So the way of the way in
like disciplining people.
Was it a lighthearted funny
way i mean she could see
that i mean it knows no i'm
going to continue to do it
but i just you know just cases like that.
I think i think it's just incredible.
They were brought up. I mean it's
really benefitted i think me.
I think it's also an hour later life down
high school still way we relate to life
and everything is totally different
because of our childhood upbringing in.
I think also just the
way we were up made us.
I mean just reflecting just
now on what jonah said
and what i think we both knew
that we'd done something wrong
and i mean before we'd even so-called
confessed our fins whatever we knew that
that was just totally out of order and
it was like i think that another.
That we've got out of our. You know it.
How we've been up brought up is
that the reason i mean maybe the reason
there wasn't such discipline in discipline
measures was there wasn't a need for it.
I mean i don't know if
that was just i mean
that was the way we brought up we knew
that that was right and that was wrong.
I mean. I mean yeah i mean
we still had disagreements.
I mean i remember there was a big
disagreement as my vegetable eating habits
and stuff like
that this this very table here was
the one we used to cram 20 people on
and i used to hate vegetables so i
used to pass them over out my head
and under the table and he gave a
broccoli i think hit my line in the leg
and she looked and there was
the diet contents of my plate.
And a will and i think that.
I mean that was amazing.
Issue but finally a guy tavy
freeman who's he was old
and he kind of i would consider him a
little brother just said because they were
hassling me that he said just
leave a line to surviving.
I think or something like that
and they did i mean i'm still not they
canned vegetables but i'm not dying
and yeah it was it was there
was another thing that.
The parents the adults had respect for
the kids. It wasn't like yes nice day.
Whatever you say just go
away and play and so i think
that because we were given respect we
could give respect and trust back and so
when we done something wrong we just say
look i've done this wrong and. But it was.
I think i speak out what so you said
earlier about tovey bringing your older
brother. That's one thing which
on the community and in nimbin.
Was a big thing i would like i would
say that it was a huge family.
I mean i see toby and jamie all these guys
and girls on the farm as my older
brothers and sisters and younger brothers
and sisters biologically caylee weren't.
What we were you know we were just as
close as they. You know like we had us.
If not close. If we had
troubles like you know i mean
when i was just a little jamie entirely
they still carry me around drag me around
in a cardboard box and i see they're
tested for their belief cards
and i mean you know.
Just one great big happy family
basically with people parents right
and a heap of brothers and sisters.
It wasn't like they were that family they
were under that surname and we were here.
Basically we're all brothers and sisters.
You know and i was just really good.
As if to say
that now being a teen as a
whole adolescent teenager.
And talking with all my friends
i would just have to say
that my childhood would have to
be probably the happiest. I mean.
Really being if i could not
have wanted it any other way.
It was just i mean i don't know if i'd
want to live there now because i haven't
been there so it's hard to say
but it was just it was just
me going through and living
and i was i think this is pretty normal.
Doesn't everyone live like this.
I mean i didn't really think
that but i just thought i.
Oh this is great and haven't
heaps of fun and fantastic
but looking back you know selecting
and all that sort of stuff.
I just have to say that oh it was
just unbelievable. I can't i.
Still i mean it shocks me myself i
still just sit back and go. Wow.
I have had the best time it was just.
Something you know
that you can i don't know if it can ever
be reproduced which is why you know i
think i'd be i'd really like it if
i had kids to my kids to do that
and i just don't know if that would
ever be able to happen but that whole.
Maybe i know the whole energy the everything
just was so even though it was new
and even though things went wrong.
It wasn't a problem and i think
that joe and i now carry that.